does anyone remember what they were
wearing when they lost their virginity
does anyone in the audience specifically
remember
the shirt oh yes really
that is so absurd i do not remember what
i was wearing when i lost my i remember
the face i was making
that was it exactly so i have some
really exciting news right up top here
uh you know it's back you know it's back
back in the whole zeitgeist here
my wife that is back
that is bet why aren't you more excited
my wife from borat is a hundred percent
back it's back my wife my wife isn't
back
my wife is still with a small italian
man but the phrase
but the framework
the phrase my life is 100 back we've
waited long enough and it's funny again
i was at a party two nights ago and a
guy was doing borat from 2006 he was
doing it now he went i like you
do you like me
and i laughed for about 15 minutes
and i'm a professional comedian
it's back it went away and we gave it
enough time i call that joke a mcrib
because it's back
and i'm loving it
that's right that's worth applauding
i'm not afraid of a stupid joke people
are joke snobs they're like oh i don't
make jokes looked up they're never happy
oh no i don't go for jokes like that
live your life live you laugh live your
life
if it makes you happy do it make shorts
and anger noises go ahead shorts shorts
and noises make shorts and noises people
like ah that's typical that's hack
everybody does that yeah cause it's fun
i do it
do it you're in your house alone waiting
for pasta to boil that's a lonely moment
pepper it out
add some spice just
boil do it
i i i
i
look at how much fun i'm having doing it
right now for you that's an amazing gift
joy listen joy is waiting for you on the
other side of a door and that door is
unlocked and there are things that can
open that door and they're like cosby do
cosby listen to me cosby do it zep do it
zebra
it works and you just watched it work on
a grown man who's having a long day flip
that little down it's a delight
people like oh it's typical everyone
does it cause it's fun as get out
of my face realty
zero to fun in one word ruby vanessa
malcolm jamal warner
you can say the actors names you can say
the characters names either way you're
in happy town dancing dancing a jig
that's the official dance of happy town
make it dirty if you need to have sex
with a girl booger
you haven't been having sex with a girl
in your green plaid shirt
and you're like i'm gonna remember this
shirt forever and we're gonna do the
shocker with the pudding pop and it's
fun it's a fun thing
and it's not an appropriate
had sex he had a bunch of kids
you know how they got here i'll put the
penis in the vagina
i'm sure if that doesn't make you laugh
i can't help you i can't
and if you're waiting on other jokes
they're going to be back they all have
like a half-life you know the radiation
will be off of them like i have a
beautiful vision of 2034
where not only is it funny but it's
actually a good pickup line to go up to
a girl and be like dude i'll make you
homey baby that's
that is coming
and that is a great story of how you
meant my wife that's right
that's a well-timed austin powers mcrib
everybody